today we are going to look at a couple
of tactics related to pawn promotion all
right this is a position that we looked
at in our last class so I just want to
review it for those of you who aren't in
that class and see how quickly you guys
can find the answer this position is
white to move what do you think the
evaluation is and this is why it's so
important in chess to visualize ahead
today we're going to talking about pawn
promotion pawn promotion is the key
concept in the endgame in the middle
game you're trying to checkmate your
opponent in the endgame you're trying to
promote upon so that you can make a
queen and then checkmate your opponent
anyway right so always keep your eyes on
the prize once you get into that endgame
and it doesn't seem you can all any
longer amount an aggressive attack now
you're trying to identify which pawns
can become Queens and how can we make
them Queens here both players seem ready
to try to make a queen so what so what
do you think is gonna happen guys
let's say how many people think that
white is going to make a queen first and
win the game how many people think the
game is gonna be a draw how many people
think that blacks gonna win the game all
right so let's take a look and see what
your analysis is white just plays h4
immediately what happens then what let's
try to analyze till the end because now
white looks like they're gonna be one
move ahead of black in this pawn race as
we call it yeah
85 and now if a tribe uh-huh and now
what mm-hmm eight six yeah uh-huh uh-huh
exactly very good now whoop I'm trying
to get the arrow
I heard to the right place but use as
you see now the White King has to move
away and black gets to swoop down and
take that Queen in right so instead what
would White's best move be in this
position instead of making a queen yeah
now oh sorry yeah now again we want to
play here why is qg6 not as good yeah
the h8 square it doesn't protect the
Queen in square right so now that's our
queen if we if we play something like
this now trying to get to the g8 Square
and protecting this square what would
black do well with blacks best movie
here Isobel queen h8 just block it
yourself and now of course it's an easy
win because the King will just come
forward and eventually the King will no
longer be able to touch base with this
pawn right so that is some good drawing
technique here for white not this
actually the other one this would be bad
right good calculation great job
all right this one is a kind of a
combination between pawn promotion and
skewers how would you play here as white
so this is a technique where we're
trying to promote our pawn here but our
work is in the way so how would you
achieve that
what's your name in the back yeah hmm
call what do you think'll to where well
if you play with da I take this pawn and
that's the pawn that you were really
hoping you would be able to make a queen
with right
if you move your king first that's a
good idea
because now you could move you're
threatening like say he plays here now
the white rook can pretty much move
anywhere and and next move
he's gonna make a queen right and it
doesn't matter if you start checking me
it doesn't really matter because I got
control over the queening square so I
can just bring my king all the way back
out of the action I don't even need the
king in the action anymore because I'm
just threatening this Queen aim square
with my rock right so I'm gonna make a
queen and I know we can all win with the
rook versus of King right raise your
hand if you can win with a recursive
King everyone's hands are going up
excellent good good good so that's a
good question but instead if you were
black here how would you play better as
black than just moving your rook to h1
or something like that it's about work
a8 excellent is a very good move because
now we want to Queen this pawn and your
only way to stop us from doing that is
to take this but then what will white do
and II work a seven check with what was
that called screw it right and he was my
earlier class where we talked all about
skewers so he see this even quicker and
that's why it's good to study patterns
and tactics because then you see things
more quickly like this so now when the
King moves away rook takes rook and
we've got oh yes he can you can take the
pawn to make it a little bit tougher
and now after Brooke takes rook we are
oh not to her rook takes rook we are
winning again and
and as we discussed earlier you guys all
know how to win with a rook versus a
king right the right angle check okay
whatever your method is as long as
you're getting it done that's the
important thing
all right let's take a look at the next
one so there are a lot of important some
people think the end games are boring
but they're not as exciting as the
beginning of the game but in reality
there's lots of excitement even in the
end of the game even with very few
pieces on the board this is one of the
most exciting chess positions out there
actually and this is going to teach us a
lot of different things about pawn
promotion about stalemate and about
checkmate
so let's take a look at this position
here it's white to move what would be
your first instinct here is white it's
about no I don't think that would be
your first instinct then promote the
pawn and make a queen right so why is
that not a spectacular winning move
after making a queen let's all think for
a minute about what white black rather
can do in this position okay let
everybody else think for a second
work this c4 you don't sound very
confident what do you think about that
move Jonathan Rick this c4 that's more
confident is well that's what you want
to do all right
is that what you wanted to do as well
good
so rook to c4 check why is that such a
good move yeah
after the Queen takes this is stalemate
this is what you want to avoid when
you're up a lot of material right when
you're up a queen the last thing you
want to do is let your opponent get a
stalemate it happens so many times be on
alert for that you see the King can't go
here right King can't go here King can't
go here how many people have been
winning in one of their games and
falling victim to a stalemate
everybody's happened to at some point
right never happened to you
only once okay that counts so good good
to be aware of it and it never has
happened to you again but in the off
chance that you end up losing material
to your opponent you can also be the one
that saves the day with a brilliant
stalemate like this one is pretty hard
to see I met right you can totally
imagine that even a very strong chess
player would make a queen here and then
miss this brilliant response right
because you're not looking always at
moves like this checks which give up an
entire rook right that's what it takes
to get to the next level to look at
those surprising moves that your
opponent doesn't even consider now to
take that to the next level of surprise
wait is actually still winning here but
so we have to adjust this position a
little bit to make this combination
actually work for riot so now it's
definitely like to move and win same
thing now if we make a queen here it's a
draw right same yeah it does it does the
other one well but then black will
actually win because we go here now Glac
can actually win the position
so what do I do instead Jonathan so now
if we make a rook what happens here so
what happens here what's a white's
threat now what is why it's threatened
in this position anybody see the threat
here yeah hmm well not actually check
mate but checkmating how what's our
threat in this position we're Kate is a
threat that's right now what can black
through to stop it
so if working for instance if you play
King here or something we've got Rick
Hayden and now work today for work takes
work is mate right so what can black do
instead how can black stop us from
playing work hey mate yeah
call what's that how can black stop this
work a8 mate well mating well work t3
yes sure we can block for one move but
then we're still gonna get checkmated
pretty quickly right so instead after c8
equals rook how else can black stop the
tech named Jacob work to a4 excellent
and now what can we do now what is
whites win here this comes back to
another tactic that's really important
yeah King b3 okay now why is that such a
powerful move what are the two things
that that moves does exactly so we have
two threats here and there's no way to
stop both of them right so if we move
the rook away we get to go checkmate and
if we try to stop the checkmate with
something like this white will actually
capture this rock well not right away
but pretty soon yeah you all know how to
checkmate with will be winning it'll be
a win anyway exactly nope
so this is a very rare example of a
situation where instead of making a
queen we make another piece has anybody
ever had a situation where they played a
game and they may not a queen but
another piece why was that true why did
you do it how about this position what
do you guys think here is this a good
example is about it's about what would
happen here right we better promote to a
knight because if we promote to a queen
here our opponent will play why Jonathan
queen takes rook and now this is just a
draw right queen versus queen unless
White has a score where he doesn't have
any scores in the position
so that's why you have to instead make a
knight now you've got a check and you
end up being up a knight and a rock
right yes better than well it's better
than just being in a draw that was
similar to your position through cool
almost exactly like that
now how about in this position guys what
would you do here for right weight to
move so we're looking at more tactics
related to trying to make a Queens and
win our games weight to move and win so
if we prep on here the bishop just takes
so what should we do yep
anyone yeah
pawn to d5 excellent blocking and now if
they go here we get to go air pawn to f7
and now we're gonna make a queen next
move right very good
no because if they take with the bishop
now what do we do now we take the bishop
first and then we make a pawn half seven
all right exactly so good job guys let's
do one more quick one why do I keep
going to other positions how about this
position how can white win here this
one's really tricky so we've got a pawn
that's trying to Queen over here right
but if we played b7 than our opponent
just plays rook take c1 check and then
just puts a rook behind the pass pawn if
we take if we take the rook then if we
take the rook then after pawn takes b7
what can black clay here that's a very
good idea of a black has a strong move
in this position this would normally be
a great idea but you have to lose all
our tactical ideas yeah
no we can't do that because this puns
going that way what can black do here
yeah
queen bee one check excellent
what does that call a fork right we're
forking the King in the pond so they
can't do that so white not to be a
little bit creative here if he wants to
figure out how to promote that pond to a
queen anybody see how what to do is
about Jonathan Queen c7 is an excellent
move also very creative the idea now is
that this one can take the Queen but
then what will white do Jacob the pawn
will take and now you absolutely cannot
prevent C 8 equals Queen right so you're
gonna be having a rook and the Queen for
a queen and be totally winning right
well good job guys so I want you all to
think about when you get to that end
game thinking of creative ways to make
your pawns into Queens all right
you